well any chef England has just announced
667 new deaths of people who tested
positive for Kovac 19 and that brings
the total number of confirmed reported
deaths in hospitals in England to ten
thousand 261 let's go back to Ashish in
the news room and her she's just took us
through these figures please that means
now that England has passed by itself
that grim milestone of more than 10,000
deaths it's ten thousand two hundred and
sixty one another 667 people reported
killed by Ovid 19 by NHS England today
but that that's the reporting period
these aren't people who have died in the
last 24 hours that is down from
yesterday's figure that was 737 and
again the same warning the same caveat
this is a bank holiday weekend there is
usually a lag in reporting and collating
these figures we've seen it before with
weekends previously where we see the
number quite low on a Monday and then
rising again on the Tuesday Wednesday
that doesn't necessarily mean that will
happen but I think it's important for
all of us to understand that the figures
taken as a snapshot in 24 hours aren't
truly reflective of a much bigger figure
and also as you said these are deaths
reported in hospital certainly not the
number of deaths taking place in care
homes throughout the country for a
regional breakdown we saw have London
reporting the highest number of deaths
and that to be expected that the capital
with the largest and the densest
population 158 of these 667 deaths
coming from London the Midlands comes
next it's a hundred and six re Midlands
is actually higher than London one
hundred and seventy deaths in the
Midlands we saw that trend last week and
it was something that was reported at
the government press conference the fact
that London seemed to be reporting in
fewer cases the Midlands certainly
becoming one of the hot spots and the
North West a hundred and two deaths
reported there so that gives you a a
national picture and a regional
breakdown but certainly 667 more deaths
are reported today again the same
warning it's a weekend we can't look
too closely at a figure reported over a
bank holiday weekend but suddenly we
will look at a trend and we'll see
whether the doubling of the death rate
continues to become longer it's at about
six days of a moment that's certainly
too early to say whether the lockdown
which was imposed exactly three weeks
ago today is reflected in those numbers
that's likely to make some sort of
impact on the number of people being
admitted to hospital and the number of
people who are dying possibly next week
or the week after